[Música]
pele humana para transplantes e testes
para cológica quantas pessoas estão à
espera de um transplante no brasil se
penteia dias segundo a associação
brasileira de transplante é e órgãos e
disse o seguinte em 2017 brasil
se existem 60 pessoas à espera de um
transplante
dessas 60 mil pessoas 56 mil adultos em
torno de 4 mil crianças e também a
associação brasileira de transplantes de
órgãos disse que por ano pessoal é
morrem 2300 pessoas à espera de um
transplante
outro dado interessante o número de
transplantados em 2015
korn aqui no brasil tá 13 mil oitocentos
e sessenta e uma pessoas coração 353
pessoas pâncreas 119 pulmão 73 e pele
pessoal 55 transplantes
a taxa de doadores efetivos para vocês
terem uma idéia no brasil apenas é 14
doações para cada milhão de pessoas no
uruguai são 2 21 doações para cada
milhão de pessoas nos estados unidos em
torno de 27 doações para cada milhão de
pessoas a doação de pele pessoal no
brasil ocorre no máximo 50 doações de
peles anuais não passa disso tá
e no brasil nós temos cinco bancos de
pad é curitiba porto alegre recife rio
de janeiro são paulo e eles sobrevivem
com resto de de pede em cirurgias
plásticas
então quando tem um grande acidente aí é
complicado tá tem que importar a pele e
esse e aí eu vou mostrar falar pra vocês
eu desenvolvi a pé juntamente com os
alunos é a pele humana artificial e essa
pele humana artificial e até isto é um
dos poucos projetos que foram
selecionados no brasil está exposto no
museu do amanhã no rio de janeiro
então o que me motivou a trabalhar a
desenvolver esse projeto foi um dia que
o a presença em grave acidente dentro de
um curtume um senhor que estava
carregando um galão com 20 litros de
ácido sulfúrico galão sem tampa e foi
subindo uma escada escorregou eo rácio
do cargo
sobre ele que move 95% do corpo e também
aqui olha é cerca de um milhão de
pessoas com queimaduras são registrados
por ano no brasil 10% música atendimento
hospitalar e 2500 pessoas morrem por ano
e são os acidentes com fogo é a maior
causa de morte na infância tanto no
brasil como nos estados unidos
então ea criação de substitutos estádio
próprio a pele a encher de transplante
está sendo uma busca dos pesquisadores
nesses últimos 30 anos
então muitas soluções a unidade só que o
problema é o bronze é processos carnes
estar pessoal ou seja até os momentos
métodos para construir uma cultura de
tecidos são muito caros então acabo que
nada os médicos acabam fazendo o enxerto
da parte do organismo para a outra parte
e quando a pessoa muito magro tem
escassez está de pé diz aí o problema já
é maior e também o paciente que precisa
de um transplante ele quase sempre tem
que vencer dois desafios que é a
escassez de órgãos por causa da as
pessoas nem dom órgãos e principalmente
a pele pessoal só que a pele quando é
doada é as partes que não vai aparecer
no velório só que infelizmente a pensar
a maioria das vezes não aceitam tá a
doação de pele e também tem o problema
de rejeição tanto de órgãos ea pele
também pele de um ser humano para outro
ser humano e na atualidade eu seja deve
ter visto na internet aqueles curativos
com pele de peixe existem também os
curativos com a tele suína
só que elas com os médicos para esse
curativo com a pele suína só que por
causa da rejeição essa pele fica até o
momento o início da cicatrização
argumento médico já retira essa pele mas
aí o que nós desenvolvemos e esse
trabalho de utilizar a pele suína em
pele e dá sobre humano chama
xenotransplante então o ator não chega o
transplante de pele é temporário sim
definitivos anos começou a estudar quais
as espécies animais que mais se
aproximava da pele humana
aí nós buscar pele suína ela tem 78% de
compatibilidade com a pele humana
então desenvolvemos metodologias pagar
transformando essa
ele suína em pele uma artificial pra que
ela ficasse tão ficar de forma
definitiva no organismo da pessoa
transplantada do paciente e sem um
processo o problema da rejeição
tá o interessante nós conseguimos
desenvolver a appele suína como ela tem
em torno de um metro e meio metro e 80
então independente até o tamanho da
lesão no organismo da pessoa
esta ideia está essa pele transformada a
pele suína transformado em pele humana
artificial com o dono de um mac nenhum é
de 80 o valor dela fica em torno de 85
reais
e esse trabalho já está sendo já tanto
que os meninos tecnologia uma indústria
que vai produzi la em escala industrial
tá então ou seja pegue uma artificial
resultante ela tem o poder de
recuperação funcionalidade da pele
humana natural porque é um modelo que
mimetiza pele humana com toda sua
estrutura de epiderme e derme e ela
permanecerá para sempre no organismo
transplantado o que acontece lá ela vai
favorecer o crescimento da pele da
pessoa do transplantado sobre ela fica
definitivo aí até por questões de
estética tempo os índices de
cicatrização
nós já estão produzindo essa pele nas
ruas próximas cores negra vermelha e
amarela e resultados né então
transplante de pele no emprego em
queimados e utilização de teste pessoal
farmacêuticos cosméticos em laboratórios
que usam da animais né ela certa
substitui a utilização de animais e
também e com esse trabalho da pessoa
humana ganhamos com o trabalho mais
premiado que nós tivemos dentro dos
vários trabalhos e eu ganhei com esse
trabalho prêmio curte política que é o
pesquisador do ano de 2014
também está incluído dos do prêmio do
conselho regional de química do estado
de são paulo ganhamos três até o momento
e um dos três pouca pele humana também
tá é lá no livro da febrace jucá usp
como espelho professores inspiradores
também ganhamos prêmios nos estados
unidos também com esse trabalho e ao
apresentamos também foram apresentados
em alguns programas de televisão como o
encontro com a fátima bernardes no
conexão futura que é do canal futura
a conversa mundial ah e também nessa
série da leitão que a história do futuro
a nossa vai ser apresentada no dia 2 de
novembro outra sede do fantástico
conhece paga grava no mundo e e com isso
essa semana que a gente teve até uma
surpresa uma reunião com o governador em
são paulo que vai estar auxiliando seja
na a melhorar essa educação básica que
tem que ser de qualidade da pessoa
obrigada é
[Aplausos]